foreign
recent developments in the crypto
industry have given us access to a brand
new financial and technological
environment the world learned an
inventive method for modernizing
traditional Financial systems which are
frequently Rife with a wide range of
problems for example liquidity pools and
other novel ideas had a lasting
impression on the cryptosphere and this
is what has brought us here hey everyone
welcome to this new video on liquidity
pool by simply learn to give you a
complete idea of liquidity pool and how
it's connected with the crypto world but
before moving on please subscribe to our
simply learn Channel and hit that Bell
icon to get updated on more such
interesting videos
so first let's have a look at what we're
going to explore in this video first you
will get an idea about what is
decentralized finance or defy then you
will understand what a liquidity pool is
following that you will understand the
difference between the liquidity pool
and ordered books then you will get a
broader perspective on how exactly
liquidity pools work and what are the
regulations of the liquidity pool and in
the end you'll get a gist of the pros
and cons of liquidity pools so let me
take you through decentralized Finance
first
decentralized Finance or Defy is a new
Financial system that is built on safely
distributed ledgers much like the ones
used by cryptocurrencies D5 reduces the
service charges that Banks and other
financial institutions impose anyone
with an internet connection can use D5
and users can hold their money in a Safe
digital wallet and transfer money
quickly basically by giving people
access to peer-to-peer digital trades D5
threatens the centralized Financial
system and crypto assets are locked into
the contracts referred to as liquidity
Pools by users of D5 protocols so that
others can use them well now that I've
mentioned liquidity pools let me explain
what exactly a liquidity pool is a
liquidity pool is technically a pool of
crypto tokens secured under a smart
contract and these tokens provide
decentralized exchanges with the
necessary liquidity they require
basically the term liquidity refers to
the ease with which one can swap a
crypto token for another because so many
Financial transactions occur within the
D5 ecosystem such Simplicity is crucial
but this raises the question of how
liquidity pulls differ from ordered
books
to understand how liquidity pools differ
from ordered books let's look at the
fundamental building block of electronic
trading which is the ordered book
simply put the open orders for a certain
Market are gathered in the ordered book
the system that matches orders with each
other is called the matching engine the
ordered book and the matching engine are
the primary components of any
centralized exchange or CeX
this concept made it possible to
communicate information efficiently and
enabled the development of intricate
financial markets defy trading however
carries out deals directly on the
blockchain without needing a central
entity to retain the funds in terms of
ordered books this creates a challenge
gas fees are incurred for each
interaction with the ordered book making
the cost of executing transactions
significantly higher additionally it
makes it very expensive for Traders who
act as market makers and Supply
liquidity for trading payers Above All
Else however most blockchains cannot
handle the throughput needed for the
daily trading of billions of dollars but
liquidity pools solve each of these
problems with ease so now that the
definition and purpose of the liquidity
pool are all clear let me walk you
through the working of liquidity pools
as discussed before in a normal
liquidity pool users are encouraged and
rewarded for staking their digital
Assets in the pool rewards may take the
form of cryptocurrency or a portion of
the trading commissions paid by the
exchanges where they pull their assets
here's an example of how it operates a
Trader using Sushi swap to invest in a
BTC to usdt liquidity pool step one go
to sushi swap step two find the BTC usdt
liquidity pool step 3 deposit a split of
BTC and usdt to the BTC usdt liquidity
pool step 4 receive BTC usdt liquidity
provider tokens
step 5 lpts should be deposited to the
BTC usdt staking pool after the agreed
upon amount of time is passed you'll be
given the sushi token you pledge to keep
it safe it can be for a set period of
time like a week or three months the
original BTC usdt pair would be
compensated with a percentage of the
commissions received from exchanges on
that liquidity pool in addition by
staking your lpts you would receive
Sushi tokens now that the working of the
liquidity pool is in front of you let me
give you a gist of the regulations of
liquidity pools for your Investments
the investment fund manager needs a
license to build a pool in addition
regardless of the jurisdiction and
investment fund license is required
whenever the pool is actively sold or
promoted to clients some cryptocurrency
liquidity pools circumvent the issue by
presenting themselves as community-owned
and distributing governance tokens the
entire Community holds the ownership
thus Regulators won't be able to go
after the owners in court however there
is a significant amount of risk
associated with joining such pools
well now that the concepts of the
liquidity pool are all clear let me give
you a look over the pros and cons of the
liquidity pool to give you a better
understanding
the liquidity pull makes trading on the
decks simpler since transactions are
carried out at current market prices
whereas it goes against the idea of
decentralization that a small group
controls the pool of funds
people can use it to lend money and get
paid in prizes interest or an annual
percentage yield in return for their
cryptocurrency on the other hand due to
lacks security measures there is a risk
of hacker exploits which could cost
liquidity providers money
it uses publicly accessible smart
contracts to maintain the transparency
of security audit information but on the
contrary there is an exposure to
Temporary loss
this occurs when a change in the price
of your assets that are held in a
liquidity pool results in an unrealized
loss as opposed to if you had just kept
the Assets in your wallet
well this was all about liquidity pool
and its related Concepts I hope you like
this video and found it interesting and
informative and if you like this video
then please like this video And
subscribe to our YouTube channel and
also if you have any questions related
to this video please feel free to ask in
the comments section our team will reach
out to you as soon as possible thank you
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here